ah school
[Music]
shootings it's a problem it's a problem
in this country now I was just up in
Canada they're much nicer than us they
don't shoot each other they stab a't
that nice it's like kind of romantic we
shoot in America much more efficient
shooting somebody's like breaking up via
text easy No Mess stabbing somebody's
like breaking up in person you see that
look in their eye you're like I know
this hard for me
too then you get back to your buddies
like how'd it go you're like of course
you freaked
out
another reason why women are better than
men you don't see a lot of female School
shooters what's going on there I Googled
it there's been two oh anybody ever
heard of them ain't that weird whether
it's gun violence or the
WNBA nobody's watching these female
Shooters man or woman got to put up some
more numbers ladies